we were filming in Atlanta right now
it's going very well it's going very
well and every day there are shots there
are images that are pairing of
characters you've never seen before on
screen that again I'm very lucky to do
what I do I'm very thankful to do what I
do and I do it because I kick out for
these hey everybody its charlie awesome
news Kevin Feige has been doing a whole
bunch of interviews for ant-man of the
wasp naturally as you would expect
people have been asking him what the
movies they have planned are for phase 4
phase 5 and everything going forward so
even though he said he has about 20
movies in his head he says that they
have firm plans through 2024 the really
cool thing is that we actually have a
pretty good idea of what most of those
movies are based on what he and the
other Marvel people have been saying for
the last year or so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos we're just
getting started they just wrapped
Captain Marvel we're gonna get a trailer
for that really soon then we'll get the
Avengers 4 title and there's a really
important giveaway announcement stuff at
the end of the video YouTube changed a
really important feature that I use for
the giveaways so I had to make a couple
of changes I'll explain that at the end
of the video first awesome bit of news
Kevin Feige like he said through 2024
that represents at least 16 to 18 movies
he said that they're now on that three
movie eight year schedule what are all
these movies that we're gonna see in
phase four phase 5 and whatever phase
six is they said that they're not gonna
be calling them phases anymore I think
we're still gonna use that term in the
fandom just to demarcate different
Avengers films so each phase of movies
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 is bookended by
an Avengers film the exception now is
Avengers 4 because there's Avengers
films back-to-back it's just so big that
they had to break it into two films so
my schedule through 2024 here reflects
that so here we go I included 2019 in
this but technically that's the end of
phase 3 so phase 4 begins with
spider-man far from home which is gonna
be the last Marvel movie in 2019
so technically 2019 is sort of a phase 3
phase 4 crossover a year but 2019 you
have Captain Marvel Avengers 4 then
spider-man far from home 2020 the only
movie that's on the schedule officially
is guardians of the galaxy 3 they start
shooting that
at the beginning of next year like
January Chris Pratt actually leaked that
so that it gives us a pretty good idea
for the timeline of how quickly they can
get movies out James Gunn just turned in
the script for guardians 3 a little
while ago he posted this screen cap
every little bit of my heart there's
probably a whole bunch of other people
on pre-production right now so it gives
you a good idea for how long it takes to
put movies together so Black Widow is
the other confirmed movie we know that
there's a script floating around but
until we hear a director has been hired
I'm gonna put it in late 2020 anytime
there's a script for one of these movies
that's already done and they're getting
ready to hire a director usually they
can get stuff into production pretty
fast they'll start casting it the
turnaround on writing a script can be
anywhere from a year to two years so
when he says that they have an idea for
a movie like there's an idea for a moon
night movie until you hear them hire
someone to write a script it's still at
least bare minimum three years away
because you have to give them a year and
then two years of production the sequels
that you know that they're gonna do like
Avengers films or black panther sequels
you can put those on the clock like even
if you haven't heard about a script you
know that they want to get those out on
a certain schedule so moving into 2021
spider-man 3 coming home that's my
favorite title right now remember home
has to be in the title coming home is
the actual name of a spider-man arc from
the comics and it's all about being far
from home so eventually he's going to
have to come back home and be an adult
like he'll be a full-blown adult
spider-man maybe even capable of leading
the Avengers I don't think that he would
be the person to do that but he's
definitely gonna be one of the senior
members by the time we get to that third
spider-man film the reason why I put
this in 2021 is just because Sony really
wants that spider-man money so it's a
little easier to schedule those once
every other year before Tom Holland gets
too old to play a kid in high school
because remember spider-man 3 is
supposed to be his senior year he'll
graduate then we'll see what Sony and
Marvel decide to do with Tom Holland
after that like he might just pop up in
Avengers films spider-man is one of the
most popular comic book characters in
the history of the world so of course
there's gonna be a lot more spider-man
even after this third spider-man film
then we have Black Panther 2 I also put
that in 2021 because they confirmed that
they're doing it but they're still
locking down their deal with Ryan
Coogler and
we don't know if Ryan Coogler has
started writing the script so if he can
start writing that next year they might
be able to get that movie out a little
bit sooner then we have the Eternals
movie that Kevin Feige has been hyping
up haven't heard anything about a script
or a director or anything like that so
that could fall anywhere in this
schedule but they're definitely doing it
so moving into 2022 so we have Avengers
5 with a probable minor x-men crossover
because hopefully this Disney deal will
clear next year and they can start
integrating those characters but I don't
think that it's going to be full-blown
Secret Wars it sounds like that's
something that's so complicated and big
that that will be like their new
infinity war that they'll build up
towards it'll be this crazy multiverse
event with a bunch of x-men characters a
bunch of Marvel characters so I just
expect them to save Secret Wars for like
six or eight years down the road but you
know whatever they want to save for like
their big book ender for the next ten
years of Marvel next up is Thor 4 point
breaks revenge remember Chris Hemsworth
said that he definitely wanted to do
another Thor film they were just waiting
for the right script and there was four
years between dark world and Ragnarok so
there is no rush to do another Thor film
so they'll do it but it probably won't
happen until somewhere later in the
schedule they just confirmed Doctor
Strange to Scott Derrickson will
probably come back but there's no script
yet so that could happen anywhere in the
schedule 2023 we have black panther 3 I
think one of the reasons why it's taking
them so long to negotiate Ryan Coogler
SH contract is because they want to
negotiate that third film so that they
can get it out a little bit quicker
after this next black panther film he
confirmed Young Avengers at some point
but I'm putting that later in the
schedule because depending on which
characters they put in that it could be
a bigger risk for them so they might
bury it in a year with the black panther
film because they know that black
panther will be super popular the 2024
is pretty much anyone's guess what they
put there maybe an Avengers film
building towards secret Wars more x-men
crossover more Fantastic Four crossover
then there's a whole extra list here of
movies that he confirmed like Nova Moon
Knight but we have no idea when they're
gonna come out because they're less of a
priority for them so we have the Hawkeye
and Kate Spencer movie that's rumored to
be in development an eternal sequel
assuming that Eternals can be
their new Guardians franchise of course
they'll make a sequel within a couple
years Captain Marvel - course they're
gonna make a sequel to that moon night
like I said still tentative date that
could be happening later in the schedule
they've talked about an ova movie then
of course a Fantastic Four MCU movie but
not before they introduce those
characters
spider-man style and civil war so
they'll probably introduce Reed Richards
in a big movie maybe Avengers 5 maybe
somebody else's big crossover film then
after that after they're established
they do a genuine MCU solo film with the
Fantastic Four but I almost forgot
another movie on the list ant-man the
wasp 3 I definitely think that ant-man
of the wasp will make enough money to
merit a third film there's too much
story that they set up for the
Microverse to not mind that in another
ant-man in the wasp movie so I think
ant-man in the wasp 3 would just be
called like into the Microverse or
something like that in most of the movie
would take place down inside the quantum
realm there's just like a lot of big
stuff that they set up I'll do other
videos about that this week because they
are kind of spoilery be sure to go see
the movie if you haven't already
the really big YouTube news so this is
actually important stuff they got rid of
the private messaging feature on the
back end of my channel like they just
basically got rid of that all over the
YouTube platform because they said that
people weren't using it but that was how
I was communicating with you guys for a
giveaway stuff so what I've done is is
I've added a business email on that page
if you win a giveaway or you need to
communicate something with me just use
that email there and that's how we'll
handle giveaway stuff going forward so
I'll mention this in the next couple of
videos going forward because it'll
probably take everybody a while to
figure out what's going on just because
they don't watch every single video that
I post so no worries we'll figure it out
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner Marco Levine please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here to learn about the Captain Marvel
Ironman Easter egg going all the way
back to Iron Man 2 and click here for my
ant-man of the wasp post-credit scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]